maybe online hate is a way to channel
hate away from real people and maybe
it's a good thing don't buy my book no
wait nope I am Nicholas booth recent TV
and today we're talking with Greg
Gutfeld the host of Fox News's red eye
with Greg Gutfeld a co-host of the five
also on Fox News and the author of his
new book the joy of hate how to triumph
over whiners and the age of phony
outrage
thank you your book concerns itself with
something you call the tolerate II who
are the tolerating the tall arathi is a
group of tolerate ex colorada ik is
somebody who claims to be tolerant until
they run into somebody they disagree
with primarily a conservative or a
libertarian or anyone who doesn't hold
their same liberal assumptions you can
only be tolerant really if you are
liberal if you have any other anything
that deviates from that belief you are
considered a a bigoted insensitive
monster I consider myself a monster you
I mean you kind of started developing
this concept of fake tolerance or
repressive tolerance where we're told
everybody's supposed to get along until
you disagree when you were a student at
Berkeley people romanticized back and
this is like I say the early eighties
and I think it was the beginning of the
politically correct movement where blank
language was under fire there were
certain things you couldn't say or there
were things that that had meanings that
you didn't understand and I think that
came from deconstructionism you you were
an English major
yes I was it was I I was pathetic
because at a certain point I realized
that in order to get good grades I had
to play the game and and write in a
homoerotic thesis on Moby Dick in which
I actually got a D well you know it's
really an autoerotic I find anyway
that's my experience well when I showed
up for the oral thesis wearing a belt
around my neck it didn't win me any
points yeah when I was at Berkeley I
wasn't extremely political in fact I
would consider myself by default a
liberal because as a teenager you kind
of all
you don't understand economics he like
free stuff and you had gone just a
backtrack of it you had gone to an
all-boys Catholic High School
Sierra High School in San Mateo home of
Barry Bonds who used to sit behind me in
Spanish class and cheat off me and you
were bigger than Barry Bonds then right
this was pre his head was the size of my
body that's later later he was a skinny
guy then mysteriously he got much larger
and that was purely from working out in
nutrition I always admired them about
well like URI for that yeah you I mean
you've worked for prevention and men's
health so you know that steroids don't
really add body mass it's it's a myth
steroids don't do anything they don't do
anything basically all you really need
is a sensible breakfast yeah but where
did you come out of that as a liberal I
remember there was a time when one of
the religious teachers asked if anybody
had done drugs and I raised my hand and
nobody else did and he said that he had
such tremendous respect for me because I
said I had done drugs in front of
everybody and that is I mean I don't
know what to me that said like wow so if
you kind of like make a stand or draw
attention to yourself in a certain way
you get points and I learned that and
then there was a debate which I talked
about in my other book on I think it was
mutually and that was the erotic memoir
Jesus only came twice yeah I don't know
what you're talking about okay I mean
you come out of a high school where it's
obviously you're supposed you know to be
liberal is to be good yeah do you go to
Berkeley where to be liberal is to be
good and then you realize it's a it's a
it's an intellectual fascism they
dictate what's good without ever having
to experience the consequences of their
own beliefs what kind of phony outrage
pisses you off there is a mirror effect
and it's you know somebody will hear
Bill Maher say something oh my god he
must be fired and then there'll be a
conservative much rarer occassions
conservative will say something oh he's
just kidding yeah and I my feeling is
they're all just kidding
you can make fun of you can do piss
Christ but you can't do piss mahom right
there's a solemn the the media will
always give a pass to liberal humor or
liberal ridicule or liberal mockery
because they are liberal in terms in
that example you can always make
of Christianity because you know they
don't you know god they're so goofy I
mean that's the stereotype is that you
know traditional religious people are
goofy and square maybe they are but
goofy and square doesn't hurt any altom
utley the dividing line here is an even
liberal versus conservative but it's
cool versus uncool everybody wants to be
cool and then you you talk about how for
instance yourself like I mean that
that's an incredibly limiting way to
talk about things so you like the the
punk band The Melvins and you like alan
west the former representative who's
known for torturing people and big proud
of it yes right and but and why I mean
talk a bit about why are you so odd that
you know let people can't conceptualize
the idea that you would be into punk
music and then have worked for the
American Spectator I guess it's just
because those circles seem to be so
separate but there is an overlap I mean
there are people like Gavin McInnes who
you've met create advice and it was in a
punk band and he's a you know he's a
conservative you've got people you know
he got like Joe Escalante of the
Vandross but then you talk about Maureen
Tucker my Tucker from The Velvet
Underground which you rightly talk about
is the coolest band ever everybody's
ripping them off and then when she
emerged recently as a supporter of the
Tea Party people are like oh oh my god
it's like oh what's wrong with them
she's so basically she is in the coolest
subset of cool and she rebels within
that she's not just Rebecca in a
rebellious band she's in one of the
greatest rebellious bands in a universe
of subversive bands and she herself is
rebelling against that she is the she is
the atom she's the pure cool and they
and you have all these idiots on blogs
going oh my god this person oh god help
her it's like shut up I'm curious about
the way we're being led towards
socialism
curious about the radical waste of money
when things that we really need and are
important get drops because there's no
money left and now I have to rethink my
love of develop meanwhile I spend my
life listening to music by people I
disagree with and I don't care I mean I
I was obsessed with The Clash obsessed
with them to a point of like um I mean
it was hero worship from I guess 77282
when they throw a crime story yeah I
interviewed Joe Strummer like and and I
got drunk with Mick Jones I love these
people and Joe Strummer though a faker
because he's a diplomat son he grew up
in the posh you know so but in any case
so so you grew up with these people and
why is it so hard for people to
conceptualize that you could they're
stupid and I generally when you run into
like I I they're musicians that I know
who are liberal and I get along great
with them because they're smart they go
like politics is almost to them like
sports to bring it back to the joy of
hate you enjoy hating people you you
kind of live on it like the other way
people live on I don't know Twix bars
yes
hate is my love so what what do you want
people to take away from the joy of hey
the joy of hate explains the
physiological response and reaction you
get from hating something I do believe
it's a it's a surge and when you're
online and when you're reading comments
on a blog that you wrote you can
actually feel that adrenaline stuff and
then you turn it around on Twitter or
wherever and you get it's a nice rush it
is it is physically like fighting that's
the joy of a people like that feeling my
feeling is you have to resist that kind
of hate because you have real people in
your life you have a family and you
should direct the hit actually now
you've blown my mind because actually
maybe maybe online hate is a way to
channel eight away from real people and
maybe it's a good thing don't buy my
book no wait no okay the joy of hate is
you don't have to love everybody or
everything in fact if you love everybody
and everything
then your love is meaningless there is
no love and a relativistic world you
happen here you are finally coming out
against Jesus Christ the the brother is
at your high school taught you well now
talk a little bit about before we go
you've got the joy of hate bus yes we
know we talked about this before this
interview and this brings back memories
of the toys that drunk fathers would buy
it the Hess gas station Christmas Eve
because they were wasted they forgot to
get a gift so they buy the gas truck and
they got this Johnny will love this at a
carton of cigarettes a card a cigarette
five dollars left over and by the
helicopter or the things they did have
like a rescue vehicle yes I'm going on a
first ever bus tour go to Florida
Georgia Alabama Tennessee Kentucky it's
it's this it's the love belt okay I own
a love belt by the way alright on that
we are going to end this debacle but the
book is the joy of hate by Greg Gutfeld
how to triumph over whiners in the age
of phony outrage he you're on Fox News
late night on redeye a great show and
the 5 at 5 o'clock Monday through Friday
and you'll be coming soon to a former
state in the Confederate states of the
United States ah yeah I'm actually I'm
gonna be at the Reagan Library
when is that Ronald Reagan no okay it's
amazing the amount of ballet tights they
have at the Museum no sniffing though
because they get thrown out for that all
right thank you very much grateful for
raisin TV I was Nick Gillespie
you